I'm actually very glad that these people
have decided to come and be a part of
this event because for one thing maybe
they've been exposed to a little bit of
Truth they don't get a lot of that so
maybe they've heard some truth tonight
but also we see the contrast we see the
contrast between people who care about
children who care about families and
those who just try to drown us out
and and who cannot engage in the
conversation we see the contrast there
which is very important but here's the
other thing
the reason they're acting this way is
because they are losing and they know it
they're losing because we're going to
pass this bill and it's going to be
illegal in this state that's going to
happen no matter what they say
and they will continue to lose as long
as we continue to fight all across the
country so when you go home I want you
to call your Congressional
Representatives I want you to go online
I want you to speak to everybody you
know walk in the truth speak the truth
to everyone
as long as we do that then we win